so i go you know what let me just shoot
these [__]
i went i popped the trunk i looked at
the [__] gun i had a pin under the
spare tire i took it out i looked at it
and i go you know what if i shoot that
idiot in the other because dead men
don't tell tails i [__] knew this
i [__] knew this going in here's why
i knew even better in 1985
i was about to leave new york and i went
to 148th street to cop a bag of [__]
weed
i was just up there and my santeria
godmother
is on 148th and broadway and i just
happened to go up there because she
would always give me 50 bucks
so i went up there she's like come in
and she's like let me read the cards for
you and all this [__]
i hadn't seen my godmother like two
years because my stepdad had gone into a
shootout in new york and she wouldn't
let him in
so he told me if you see that [__] don't
ever [__] talk to that [__]
i gave her tons of money and i'm shot
and the guy is shot and he won't let me
in
my father was from a different [__]
planet you know these are nice [__]
people they don't want somebody bleeding
in their house
and i didn't care i knocked i loved this
she was good to me as a kid and she goes
let me throw the cards for you and she's
like
you're doing cocaine and she didn't know
me to do that stuff when i ran with her
she knew i hated drugs and stuff
and she goes plus stop doing that
because you're going to get yourself in
trouble and don't do business with three
people
don't ever get involved with three it's
always gotta be two or four
because two people could always turn
against you right there all these
[__] thoughts are going into my head
all these [__] thoughts they told me
i knew not to do business with these two
idiots i [__] knew it going in
the only way i'm going to solve this
[__] problem is to shoot these
[__]
that's the only way i solve this [__]
problem
i took it i cracked that [__] gun i
put in the back i looked around
i knocked on the [__] door and
tidwell was like what and i looked at
him
and he was so [__] weak as a man i
was like what would i gain from shooting
this [__] [__]
and this other [__] [__] that let
this happen to him
he didn't even see the [__] score
he's so coked out
all of us are gonna get what we [__]
deserve but you know what i still gotta
live with myself and ain't worth having
these two dummies blood and at that time
america's most wanted
just started coming on so i knew this
[__] they would find you listen if i
ever done something bad and i went back
to north bergen you have to come in
there with an army to get me
because i grew up with those cops and
they would tell me [__] everything i
grew up with the d.a
the d.a in my hometown just got busted
for bringing weed from here to [__]
and north to north bergen i grew up with
these savages
it's in our heart we're all [__]
savages at the end of the day we are
what the [__] you
are you can put a suit on me a sweater a
stage i'm a [__] savage and that's
just how it is
and i should have killed this
[__] but something something was
like joey
get in the car go [__] kick that door
down and
salvage those kilos because hopefully
this [__] didn't get it
guys he had a doorman and that whole
thing you know when you walk into a
building there's a guy with a hat
and they open the door for you when i
got out of the car the guy would usually
say to you like that time he was like
who are you here to see
he could tell when i pulled up by my
body language he just opened the door
and didn't even [__] ask
that's the body language i didn't think
about it till that night like that guy
would have to i know those buildings in
boulder they had those people they pay
them [__] good so
they asked questions this guy seen me
come with his little [__] hat on his
little ice cream hat on
and he just opened that door and put his
head down and basically as i was hitting
the door the lord was right there with
me because some lady was getting her
mail and she was going in
so i went after her i pressed [__]
three i went up to the third floor i
mean guys i went like a [__] like
outlaw josie wales there was no stop i
was like the terminator
that off the elevator went bing and i
just went down the hallway
i went up to the door there was no
knocking there was nothing i had that
piece behind me
i kicked that [__] door down and i
went in and that ceiling hangs it's a
suspended ceiling
i got my gorilla [__] jeans i jumped
up and i pulled the [__] whole
ceiling down they went bam
blood was on my hands i didn't give a
[__] i was taking this coke and i was
leaving town
also i heard boom and there's dust and i
look over there's this baggy
and it was wrapped with colombian
newspaper the [__] mother lode right
there
i sat and even read what the weather was
in bogota
the week before you know what i'm saying
i was like it was 86 in bogota two weeks
ago ain't this a [__]
look at this [__] i picked up that coke
i put in a [__] brown paper bag
i walked down the stairs like i owned
the building i went in the drawer there
was no cash in there the grinder was
gone the blow was gone but i had the
[__] four pounds
i walked out of that [__] i did
an old school trick i thought the cops
were looking for him i thought this guy
was gonna call the cops
i got my car and i drove and i pulled
over and there's those newspaper
machines
you put a quarter in you know those
[__] things idiots that you pop open
next time you pop it open look at the
bottom there's a little stash down there
that's old school that's where the old
school coke dealers used to put this
[__] that's why whenever i get a paper
i always look in the bottom it might be
a jackpot you know what i'm saying
[__] the internet nobody gives you a
pound of coke on the internet when you
look at a paper
for a [__] quarter ba-boom it's like
vegas so pay attention to the important
things people okay
so i said [__] it i don't want the cops
following me i hit it in there that's
old school [__]
and i went home and i called my buddy at
the dealer and i said listen
go to that newspaper thing and just go
straight to aspen i got a guy up there
that's waiting for the four [__]
pounds
just take it right up to ask me and i'll
call them tell them i'm on the way
take it sell it and come right the [__]
back get the cash don't get the cash
having western union
i knew this guy for years i said just
just get rid of it
there's going to be a [__] problem i
took a little piece out of it you know
me how to celebrate
solo i took a little piece i stopped at
the liquor store i bought like a [__]
whatever a beer and i went home locked
the door and i just snorted and thought
of what my next
move was i didn't know what was
happening over there
that night about 10 o'clock he knocks on
my door tidwell he's like where the [__]
are you
i got a dilemma i got to get this guy
out of the [__] city and i'm like
it's 10 o'clock i left you with two
you didn't get him on he's like we gotta
go back and find the coke and i'm like
we can't go now the guy is there he
didn't know that i had already shipped
the [__] coat
the coke was already on the way to aspen
it was out of my possession
the scale was out of the house
everything i [__] knew something was
going to happen i was just going to play
it out a couple days i was going to see
if i get the money
and fly out i couldn't make a plane
reservation my plan was to drive out of
new mexico or vegas or something like
that just to avoid anything
i [__] he leaves he threatens me
again i go you know what the [__]
mood i'm in you dumb [__] you
got away with murder before
you've been stoned and you're driving
down a block in the valley or in
hollywood there's an idiot next to you
on a bicycle
and you're really high and you almost
hit them and
and you realize you almost killed the
[__] he just don't know he's
riding with his helmet all [__] hat
and you want to pull over and say you
don't know how lucky you just came to
die
and i'm saying you ever get that high
you just zoom past the bicyclist and
you're like
that [__] don't know it's his
lucky day
[Applause]
i didn't see that guy i definitely
didn't see that guy
[__] him that's how lucky this guy was
like i felt like saying you don't know
how lucky you were dog
i spared you and i'd spare that other
[__] loser
get the [__] off my balcony by this time
i got the blowing me
i'm wound up i already told the
girlfriend not to come down i was gonna
jerk off that night i had to think
i had to go into deep [__]
concentration about what my next move
was because i knew there was heat
he left and some part of that i just
passed out and drank
you know when you pass out you don't
even remember pass out you just
wake up and your zip is open and there's
a phone next to your dad
my zipper wasn't he i just woke up to
you know one of those [__] things and
i go to the window and i look
and this is the detailer at the subaru
place the in-house guy
blazing brent little [__] crazy irish
[__] crazy
this guy would eat snort pills and glue
and
banana tablets this guy didn't give a
[__] he'd be back there buffing cars
all day just sweating how are you good
he'd just be out there [__] sweat
he shows up he's like dog listen i mean
to wake you up but they got the [__]
building surrounded at the dealership
and they're about 10 minutes behind me
they're in there right now wayne's
[__] throwing them off
he took me in the back and said go over
and wake him up and get them out of here
i get dressed i get my [__]
everything i kiss the dog i feed the dog
as i'm [__] walking across the street
i see the cops coming down my block
those two [__] idiots like a black
and white
and a regular unmarked car and i cross
the street and i go across the street
and i call my girlfriend at the
hair cutting place and i go hey uh you
got to pick me up
there was a problem with tidwell you got
to pick me up as soon as possible i
didn't even know what happened at this
point
i just knew something happened the cops
were looking for me
i [__] uh after i hang up
i go for my weed and you can't leave the
house without your weed
and i had good weed like i was getting
this buddha thai weed sent out from
jersey that chocolate [__] that jamaican
smoke and dreadlocked their hair
i couldn't just leave it in the [__]
house this is how crazy i was i said
[__]
i'm going back to get that [__] wheat
i don't care what cops are waiting for
me
so i went i walked like two [__]
blocks crossed the street and walked the
side streets to my backyard behind
jumped the fence went in the house you
know while i'm in the house getting the
weed i look out and there's a cop car
out there waiting for me like unmarked
there
i got my weed i [__] went out the
back door and i remember when as i was
crossing there was another car coming he
looked right at me
i'm like this is not like a tv show they
would already had me if this is a tv
show what [__] kind of cops are these
idiots
i just went and got my weed walked
around so i get back to route or king
super as it was
and there's my girlfriend she takes me
up to the house and i go up there and
once i get to the house i start making
calls and i found out
vela tidwell put vella in the trunk of
the car
he was going to drive him to denver to
take a bus the midnight bus
but when he left my house he forgot to
put his headlights on
are you ready
he got pulled over for no headlights on
and when the guy asked him for the
registration he heard
he goes what the [__] is going on he
pulled his gun out
they opened the trunk and there's
[__] vela that's the luck i got
that's the [__] luck this is how deep
god was going to get me for this one
god was getting me it all came down to
[__] not turning your headlights on
okay food for thought [__] if
you ever kill somebody put your
headlights on
that's what i found out it's in the
paper it's in the paper that they found
them a
drug situation and that my name was
they're still looking for a third victim
so i just stood up there for like two
days
finally the second day i couldn't take
it they lived in the mountains i came
down i rented
above the law it was just out brand-new
and lethal weapon was just that was the
hot [__] movie on
on uh vhs you know so i was out of weed
too so i had to go to a weed dealer get
some weed
but when i go to the video store my
buddy at the car dealership said listen
the detective came and gave me a card
you should call him the guy seemed okay
he wasn't okay it's good
cop back up so i got the kid's number
and i [__] called the uh the cops but
i called them from a kmart
and there was an albertsons across the
street in a coco's restaurant
and i called him who came and i want to
talk to detective whatever and he goes
hold on one second who's calling joey
diaz
they had me on hold trying to trace the
[__] call well i hang up i watch a
lot of tv shows dawg
and at that time there was no discovery
there was none of that [__] we had three
[__] channels but you learn
after like 36 seconds they'll [__]
trace that [__]
so i called back again and they're like
hold on one second i hang up on him
again
again hold on one second i go listen
you're gonna keep putting me on trace i
just want to talk and see what happens
he goes this is
detective whatever jose he goes you got
a lot of problems here
just come in tell us what happened and
we'll let you [__] go
and he goes where are you and i look
around i go i'm at albertsons
he goes i'll be there in two minutes to
talk to you i hung up the phone i rang
to my [__] car and just sat there
within minutes i seen [__] trucks
and helicopters and [__] cops all
bust into albertson's with their guns
and i'm like [__] it i'm in trouble
i took that car and went back up to the
mountains and went into thought
it was friday right so i said [__] the
detective told me to come down
talk to him and he let me go home that
was the night that don johnson was going
to marry sheila easton on miami vice
and i had plans to stay home and watch
that wedding that night
i was i had the tuxedo you know what i'm
saying i was going to sit there by
myself
[__] it don johnson was getting married
i was ready so
that was well should i turn myself in or
should i wait till after the wedding you
know what i'm saying
that was stuff and you guys think i'm
[__] with you i'm dead serious
like i had spare ribs for that night i
was gonna get chinese food
i was gonna [__] my girlfriend i had a
lot of plan we were going to a wedding
[__]
so i'm like you know what [__] the
wedding how
whatever tape it and watch it let me go
down there and talk to them
but i always knew that you don't talk to
[__] cops if you do talk to them just
talk about
something completely different if they
ask you about a robbery talk to them
about
the pictures [__] mickey mouse drew
in 1958 just
i don't know you know and they get
thrown off and they get furious and then
they can't have a conversation with you
because they think you're actually like
tidwell [__] half [__] so that
was my that's what i always do i just
throw riddles at them you know i'm
saying that
so i tell my girlfriend i go listen drop
me off about ten we had a nice breakfast
we smoked a joint i go
i'll go talk to him i'll be home by four
or five we'll watch the wedding
i'll be on a few [__] hours we'll
watch the wedding get what you were
gonna get here's some cash let's do this
love you bye i go into the police
department i got to go into bowl the
police i go up to a window detective
whatever
they go who are you joey diaz they go
walking through that door
walk in through that door when that door
buzzed and i walked in
every [__] cop in there put his
weapon get to the [__] floor
i'm like you just invited me in you know
what i'm saying
how [__] rude are you [__]
draw me i don't even wipe my feet
throwing me on the floor
get down get down like all this
dramatics i was like all these [__]
idiots